your las vegas raiders have five games
remaining at home this season
including this sunday against the denver
broncos and our eight sports now crew
will kick things off with a special half
hour show it's going to air saturday at
4
30. but first reporter molly sullivan
has our week 10
game preview somehow someway the raiders
are 5
and 3 as they enter the second half of
the season favored in only one game las
vegas just continues to find a way
as john gruden put it adversity is
sometimes a perception
and there's a lot of perception out
there but the reality is
this group is extremely tight and it's
all based on respect they're also
thriving
on adversity whether it's self-inflicted
or otherwise
winning despite a revolving door in the
offensive line where the starting unit
has only played three snaps together
while you're letting that sink in
consider this the only other quarterback
not named patrick mahomes to have zero
interceptions when kept clean this
season
derek carr pick any stat number four is
getting the job done his legs
are becoming just as valuable as his arm
with his mind running the show for what
many consider to be the toughest
schedule through the first nine weeks
next up the denver broncos who have
trailed in the first half by double
digits in
five of their eight games this season
you may be thinking hey it's not how you
start it's how you finish
copy that the broncos are three and five
and when we look at how the raiders have
owned
the third quarter that's a point of
emphasis winning teams build on
outscoring the chargers 14-3 in the
third last sunday
the raiders are averaging the ninth most
points in the first 15 minutes coming
out of the locker room
while allowing the fourth fewest last
season the raiders put up the fewest
third quarter points in the league
and they also allowed the second most it
all adds up after going
4-1 on the road the raiders have five
games remaining
at home this season looking to go 3-0
against the afc west with a victory over
their division rivals this sunday
at the intermountain healthcare
performance center i'm molly sullivan 8
sports now